une production du studio sfr
bienvenue au sans fil de représenter
parquet smith et le podcast où on parle
de ce qu'on veut nous inviter date si
czm et afghans d'un mois dôme planque et
gasmi vient toujours de lancer leurs
collections diverses et pour les
amoureux du temps des fêtes pour les
amoureux de la féerie des neiges c'est
pour ceux qui aiment les activités
hivernales c'est plus de 40 nouveaux
design 40 nouveaux des sommes allés voir
ça pour habiller votre selle pillon
aussi des nouvelles d'un nouveau
chargeur à induction en fait qui fait
que moi j'ai cherché nous vous mettez
vous déposez votre selle dessus sa
charge automatiquement prennent des
couleurs plein bourg d aller voir ceux
utilisés avec le promu sf crise pour
profiter de la magie pays du temps des
fêtes sur votre cellulaire cette semaine
dès cette semaine grand grand plaisir de
recevoir victoria culte c'était vraiment
un beau podcast une belle rencontre avec
une fille travaillant tu as fait pas mal
à personne travaillant que j'ai
rencontré dans ma vie ça n'a aucun sens
tous car a construit comment elle a
travaillé fort pour se rendre jusqu'à
les maintenant une entrepreneure
inspirante vraiment c'était super cool
on ne parlait justement de son parcours
du salut vient cette fibre
entrepreneuriale le de ces différentes
détenir ces différents projets ont aussi
tout un retour sur sa carrière dans
l'industrie du x alors comment ça se
passe et comment c'est comment cité
commerçante et là dedans qu'est-ce
qu'est ce que le but que j'ai deux
parties qu'avait donc
donc c'est toujours sur une curiosité
savoir un peu comment ça se passe dans
ce milieu là mais aussi elle skie
vraiment inspirant ce qu'elle est
toujours une vision un objectif à
visualiser votre avis en aller puis à
l'atteindre chercher
iriez qui est impossible pour tous
véhicules alors bien content d'avoir
reçu c'est une d1 des podcasts les plus
motivants des derniers temps des fêtes
moi je suis comme un crack et on vient
juste d'enregistrer en tout cas encore
bongrain qui fait que je joue en ligue b
on va remercier nos sponsors avant de
blesser la conversation bompas
le podcast de cette semaine et présenté
par nos amis chez même skate dans le
cadre du temps des fêtes qui s'en vient
on a décidé de gâter nos auditeurs fait
qu'on va faire tirer un ensemble perfect
paquet du 4.0 et wind waker ces quads
homme qui a des preuves etc package et
ckoi wire fabric laquelle j'ai tout ce
qu'ils avaient besoin pour la gestion de
votre pilosité d'entretien rosoirs
électrique le lower 4.0 qui le plus
efficace qui voit le plus que vous
perdiez dans la douche pour ranger vos
parties et un ami aussi des déodorants
et des boxes à la die tout inquiète
vraiment complet et il ya le wind waker
moi j'ai un problème de poils donné j'ai
souvent dit pas le nez trop long qui
dépasse peas et anna puis ça passe pas
inaperçu on remarque sa dépouille ait
mis trop long feu un mot j'ai hâte que
comme tel chef bob gars qui est venu ici
les faits voici ouais
on remarque c'est un gars qui est à des
belles la reine tout klinsmann important
donc c'est rock au fait des concours
qu'on fait rideau faire profiter en
mariage et aux tories qui méritait vous
inscrire exact pour le dernier en fait
simplement fait une story instagram ou
est ce que vous partagez le podcast de
cette semaine attaquant le sans filtre
podcasts et en taguant une personne que
vous connaissez qui a besoin de se
reposer les couilles date site et pour
tout autre besoin chez minsk et pendant
un code promo pour vous sans filtre en
un mot pour 20% le rabais avec la
livraison gratuite avec le temps des
fêtes qui s'en vient on connaît tous
quelqu'un qui a besoin de se ranger les
banquiers
le podcast de cette semaine et présenté
par nos amis chez walter meier on en
parle souvent parce qu'on les aime qui
parce que les produits c'est de la bombe
- je reçois nombre de commentaires de
personnes que leur chien adore la
nourriture de wilder sérieuses et des
produits hypoallergéniques éco
responsable produit ici au québec par
des gens d'ici pizzotti évidemment on
adore les produits québécois céder les
produits incluent des gâteries à base de
grillons et des gâteries vegan la base
de d'algues et de pulpe recyclé elle
travaille avec elle ou puni compagnie
qui qui fait des débuts avec des fruits
recyclé ayant volé pull à ward qui font
des gâteries pour chier avec ça ils font
aussi des nourritures à base d'eau à
base d'insectes et de nourriture pour
chiens à base de protéine alternative
nomme comme la carpe asiatique qui est
un poisson un fait qui est un parasite
qui détruit les fonds marins qu'il faut
pêcher et on les réduit les réutilise
dans cette nourriture donc tout le monde
est gagnant la nourriture ou de rêver
yeux et aussi nutritive
sinon plus que le saumon plus protégés
que le boeuf et les chiens on raffole
apparemment que c'est vraiment beau ou
bout pour eux-mêmes pour nous mais comme
je serai pas mais
si une avancée local hypoallergénique
ces éco responsable c'est disponible sur
le web alors profitez-en on a un code
promo pour vous qui le sf 20 pour 20% de
rabais sur leur site web mon chien sont
le monde point ca on sait comment vous
aimez vos chiens donné la nourriture
qu'il mérite et voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
retourne le banc en tant
qu'un des requins de choucroute à québec
on attendait monts et fabriqué sur
l'angle
500 kw louis nicolle ouais ça dans une
sacoche
apple commencé un peu hein
petit arrivent épuisés faut trouver un
surnom plus est en fait une connerie
mais taper nicole qu'il fait la première
personne qui est venu c'est une dizaine
d'ados qui
a rang dans le studio cliff et halo moi
c'est nickel si on venait de langage le
métro je trouve ça drôle mais finalement
c'est devenu son oncle semences et c'est
rendu normal web et tout le monde pense
comme elle
mais c'est qu'au début il l'assumé pas
maintenant la chaume à 100% avec les
gens ils sont qu'ils prennent comme plus
au sérieux questionne campoli a reçu les
ministres des finances du québec si joe
quinones jo pis il s'est présenté en
tant que nicole
faire
grincer point tout le monde
l'achète à
90 qui
m'a marqué le trouvais tellement chômage
apple and the hasty kj choi le quota à
l'écouté de ceux hostiles
[Rires]
à l'eau alors à chanter
les femmes d'affaires les plus
influentes au canada bell socialement
martial prendre non mais c'est vrai
c'est en fait trois ans incroyable
puisque pour ceux qui ont été nommés
pour ce prix le mois les prix comment ça
s'appelle existants et habib sy
taxer les plus
c'est comme les faux abstrait un intérim
et au canada puis tu étais j'ai quand
même réussi un courriel que tout dans le
premier planificatrice financière des
entreprises et toute l'équipe de la
banque royale du lieu par mon ami n'est
plus ma candidature est une candidature
plus ils m'ont mis dans les top 100
watts dans le top dix mille facettes du
top salvaza l'état
piteux comme un jeu quiz je croyais pas
j'avais qui on allait bien puisqu'elle
mais je travaillais fort mais on dirait
que j'assumais pas le titre en bourse a
jeté comme un îlot dans la tête ça n'a
pas de boomers
on voyait rarement
ddd gmt mais parce que plus fou c'est
comme pour observer une furie c'est
vraiment comme les gens succès en mode
30 heures mais comme les affaires au
canada chaussettes jaunes et des
personnes plus âgées
t40 qu'après 10
ans blessé mais comme à
ton petit peu
convaincant vite de business santoul mon
dieu qu'est ce que tu es et ce que tu es
tout sous la main business où tu as
vraiment site business de
moi j'ai la maison mère d'els par
victoria côte et puis après ça j'ai les
souhaits les compagnies de gestion à ce
que j'ai supplément rgs ne sape qui est
une entité séparée donc j'ai une
application pour femmes sur ios android
android fait que ceux-ci séparer fait
c'est comme la même affaire de la même
compagnie mais je n'ai pas le choix les
séparer pour des questions financières
py.g l'estonie studio speq engager des
studios de photos le green house qu'il
est tout blanc j'ai des boissons taxes
et une boisson
oui car oui égal de bois amanda vitamine
b2 b6
0500 rien cédé 0,4
fonctionne si je vous avais plein de
cela
[Rires]
fait longtemps le sport n'est pas
quelqu'un que j'ai lancé cette bande là
avec mon chien puis mon père nous
c'était comme les jantes elle me semble
que tu prends de la santé mais ge com
ecoute-moi samarie à défaut de prendre
un verre mais tellement que je bois pas
beaucoup que ce pantin le web je prends
un verger qu'à ce moment-là tête le
lendemain fait qu'en plus c'était un
meeting parce qu'on donne mon point de
la hague dans le fond c'est celui qui
produit mais supplément et puis on est
en train de célébrer la croissance puis
on a bien une petite brosse on n'avait
aucunement la tête et on a dit aux gens
que le lendemain et sa consoeur
appréhension mais je pense que je peux
nous faire une formule du super easy
fait qu'ils aient sorti c'est là on est
rentré à court ni à 5,5 le stock pareil
leur a quand même rapidement basket yves
le quoi ces tentes étaient même pas au
québec la fête le tt construit ce cet
empire le quand même hein c'est un
[ __ ] moi parce que je suis revenu au
québec et un
2004 2015
c'était quoi par quoi la première étape
m 4,4 venu ici c'était quoi le premier
mouvement et on te fait business mais là
je me suis mis à étudier en immobilier
j'avais investi dans des condos le
j'avais fait des flèches j'avais revendu
j'avais remis de l'argent dans la bourse
qui le je me suis dit j'aimerais
vraiment c'est investir dans
l'immobilier moi j'écoutais tout en les
testant innocence et puis j'étais
vraiment inspiré par sap par contre au
fur et à mesure que je complétais make
up quand je l ai passé mon examen
l'oaciq j'ai vite réalisé que c'est
quelque chose qui demandaient des 57 des
59 des week-ends piste à maputo mal de
temps 5 fait que je me suis dit est ce
que c'est le mode de vie que je peux
avoir avec une vie familiale dès que je
me suis dit j'ai fait des choix je me
suis dit d'ouvrir le dossier nafti sacre
face ma famille non
puis mon pied me savais mon premier
diplôme que je m'entraîne m'en priver
j'avais 19 ans je l'avais j'avais des
clients anticipent la mais vraiment pas
beaucoup si je pousserai pas de plus
pour le fun puis dans l'impact était
saturé ce domaine là puis toutes mes
clientes que j'avais j'étais vraiment
dit ça fait longtemps que j'ai dans ce
domaine depuis que je m'entraîne depuis
que je suis dans le milieu sportif
et mes clientes avaient vraiment des
gros résultat qui est comme s'il faut
vraiment y fasse de quoi avec ça fait
que je me suis dit je vais continuer mes
études là-bas en fait que j'ai laissé
faire immobilier j'ai continué mes
études en nature ou en remise en forme
prénatales et postnatales entre l'al
hilal et ses longues loin de l'aspect
science etc
puis le j'ai commencé ma business et erp
j'ai commencé à entraîner des clientes
au projet mme dans un petit local comme
300 pieds carrés il faut que je dorme et
au jam bon j'avais des clients tels
produits moi je termine mon lac à la
nage en plein coeur du matin j'avais des
clients jusqu'à en avoir le soir je
collais je voulais vraiment essayé de
bill et ma clientèle à fond la caisse
parce que je voulais à presse xpand
prend dé prendre des entraînements qui
travaillent pour moi puis après celle
léguée ses clientes c'est ça parce que
au début d'une affaire de même le sait
c'est toi qui isole tout le temps mais
j'imagine que tu peux même pas compter
les heures creuses en semaine parce que
si justement dit parce que maintenant
j'imagine qu'ils avaient des trous dans
son horaire ou est-ce qu'il faut que tu
restes là quand même parce que des
horaires pas possible de clients ah
ouais mais qui ont demandé d'échec parce
que je mangeais pas n'avait pas le temps
d'aller manger n'avait pas le temps tu
combien de combien dehors mettons dans
ces années-là d'en avant que tu
commences à déléguer à quelqu'un d'autre
combien d'autres je pense que tu faisais
de coaching pris
le soin
c'est débile sauf les week-ends
j'aimerais seront appelés week end puis
des fois même jallet
je mets des places et
des fois si j'avais une cliente spéciale
je mets des places et puis aller
directement chez elle mais c'était faux
c'est fou
j'accroche là dessus parce que des fois
qu'un convoi
des histoires
comme la tienne qu'on voit si t'es rendu
maintenant tu sais si c'est dur
d'imaginer tout ce qu'ils voient en
arrière puis les premières les premières
journées de du groënland et où est-ce
que tu le fais tu dans le fond on n'ose
imaginer une famille qui est rien et on
a grandi avec zéro argent je viens d'une
famille immigrante qui sont venus de la
russie ma grand-mère était à la guerre
s'est fait que nous aurons un grand thé
avec absolument rien fait moi je pense
que c'est là où est ce que j'ai les
valeurs de travail très très très fort
en moi qui je voulais m'assurer d'avoir
tout c'était pour ma famille puis que t
on appris moi je me suis renforcé la
vigilance des jo d'helsinki la
magnifique manifestation qui qu'un que
je me suis dit je la vois ma famille
avant 30 ans j'avoue ma maison signée
jetons comme joueur x kenji ou alien
avant 30 ans j'en achetais
s'est tissé des liens des niaiseries de
même que tu dis est qu'ils jouent à
atteindre ce niveau là puis je me suis
répété je vais répéter répéter jour
après jour que c'est ce que je voulais
atteindre peu juste financièrement mais
d'avoir la liberté financière que j'ai
de pouvoir investir de pouvoir aider les
gens à travers ma passion fait que le
fait de venir d'une famille où il n'y
avait pas beaucoup d'argent je pense ça
m'a vraiment moulée dans la workers
league c'est un mal pour un bien mais en
même temps c'est que je vous avoue le gg
1 bernard les deux dernières semaines
dans ce que j'ai vraiment goryl et
titane et la cie moule ça a été l'enfer
tout ce que j'avais à faire mais ça
reste que le faut que je réajuste un peu
mon horaire ni ma façon de travailler
parce que le pattern que j'ai depuis les
sept dernières années ce n'est pas
nécessairement le parton que je suggère
à tous les entrepreneurs que nous avons
pour la vie non plus n'ont enfin parce
que je me suis dit justement je peux
coach et du monde de 5h30 en allant de
soi mais le jeu que la même affaire mais
derrière moi
derrière un meeting en plus ne pas le
contact humain c'est plus comme ce temps
dans un meeting six pilotes je fais
moins les choses que j'aime faire puis
je m'en rappelle le chic ans que je
traîne consommons diem le gars qui est
venu livrer mes machines il me regarde
et me dit ce pique nique sur une [ __ ]
entraîner dans une coupe de moi
j'attaque à marfaux cas ça fait partie
de ma vie c'est vraiment si c'est ancré
dans moi c'est juste d'être en santé de
m'entraîner ça me fait du bien qui ça
fait quatre mois je me suis entraîné
j'ai pas le temps j'ai pas le tissu
c'est un bon signe ouais fex pour ce jeu
comme faut vraiment que je commence à m
me ouais mais fait coacher personnes
soit bon pour le training en même temps
mais si je le faisais jamais même
faisait pas mon nom parce que je voulais
vraiment focus et sur la cliente
d'instruction mouvement était parfait
c'est moi je fumais beaucoup et sur
instagram touche je voulais vraiment
cliniquement soit top notch pour pas que
ce soit tout croche plutôt que je
m'entraînais pas nécessairement avec mes
clientes plus que fait autres avoir un
plus
tout ce travail là où tu vois ce comme
un coup à donner pour construire quelque
chose qui apprécie toutefois way pottas
soir là tu me poses toi quelque chose de
solide sur lequel après ce petit famille
m'avait alors fait un peu plus ou moins
cinq hommes françois lambert c'est un
des amis à montrem puis si une grande
inspiration pour nous qui viendra un peu
le même background beaucoup d'argent
puis qui a travaillé fort fois parfois
même chose avec nicolas duvernois je le
connais super bien tu es dans le temps
le camp qui commençaient leur origine je
me rappelle il faisait des conférences
puis échos de la première conférence que
j'étais avec avec nicolas il devait pas
voir puisque cinq ans personne n'en
finissais allait y travaillaient à
saint-françois une colonne les eaux
reçues les deux seuls parce qu'à 110
fera françois encore à ce jour je sais
pas comment qui fait lundi son oral sa
discipline c'est camille sée qui sait
que le travail pipé les dés sont
en baisse c'est incroyable qui ne
connaît aussi son histoire des débuts
l'artiste et comme il ya tout mais s'est
mis en ligne tout misé sur la dessus
puis si ça
ça a payé métissée un move risque il
commet jamais vu fox pour ça pour moi
c'est d'aider grande inspiration pour
moi parce que au québec surtout parce
qu'on vient pas du même background pis
si dumont qui ont vraiment vraiment
vraiment travailler beaucoup plus
vraiment tout investi tout risqué si ça
aurait pu même être au détriment de la
famille tout à fait
tu parles de visualisation plus de
manifestations est ce que c'est quelque
chose que tu fais depuis longtemps dans
le fond maman et astrologue
pièce est encore ancré en moi depuis
tout jeune je peux tu le définir on
attend la manifestation pour
bé à travers du yoga la méditation
de se rappeler certains mots clés de ce
faire des vigiles bauer de se faire des
notes de faire du jogging
de se rappeler ce qu'on veut atteindre
puis de les cochers à chaque fois qu'on
les atteint depuis avec la méditation je
trouve que la façon comment quand on
plonge dans notre subconscient cancon
plongeon à 10 concerts on est capable de
changer nos habitudes
puis nos habitudes qui peut être dépensé
de l'argent dans le vide ou avoir des
modes de vie peut-être un peu moins sain
le fait de pouvoir plonger dans notre
conscience nous aider à changer nos
habitudes pis ça semble un peu compliqué
mais quand que tu tapes une telle date
n'importe quoi et n'importe quoi est il
possible puis c'est des choses que j'ai
j'enseigne à mes clientes puis je le
vois à quel point ça fonctionne je
travaille beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
avec la méditation et puis ça excuse
est-ce que depuis le début de ta
pratique en tant que coach privé c'était
quelque chose que tu connais c'est aussi
quelque chose qui te comme appris
pendant ce parcours l'appui que tu es
très prudente à tabouk dans ta pratique
depuis forever alors depuis toujours
toujours toujours toujours je quelqu'un
qui a toujours vu comme ma vie
je
la vois 50 ans maintenant comme jessica
ce que je vais faire puisque je brandis
même si je vais avoir comme dit
geagea ma part j'ai ben je vais toujours
fini par me rendre là où est ce que je
devrais me rendre ça c'est par force ça
me fascine ce mois dans le sport je les
apprécie beaucoup et je fais du sport
longuement les petits je pouvais dire
exactement
combien de coups de brosse j'allais
faire dans longueur de la course qui
s'emmenait parce que j'étais capable de
la voir le site difficile à décrire je
le trouve le footsie le vois je le
voyais comme si j'étais capable de
ondres et d'être une caméra puis de me
voir en troisième personne faire ça
quand je fermais les yeux le fils à sa
tête cette contrainte physiquement
puis je te le dis ça fonctionne c'est
débile c'est débile c'est je le fais
avec mes clientes ont paru lifting
quand même que tu leur demandes de
s'imaginer aux autres pipelines le train
c'est débile c'est fou tout me parler de
sa musique aussi que les musiciens qui
des fois pouvait ne pas toucher un
instrument pendant un vraiment longue
période de temps puis jouer dans leur
taille puisse avoir joué puis reprendre
instruments puis a quasiment aussi bon
importe quel quotidien efforts mécanique
mais 35 où je serai quand même le mot
c'est quelque chose que c'est maintenant
très mushishi guitariste de formation de
cépie maintenant je vais vraiment moins
de temps à l'aise physiquement avec
l'instrument c'est sûr que si je pense
puis si je pense à l'élite une que je
vais devoir jouer si je pense à mes
affaires
j'arrive c'est cent fois mieux que si
comme j'avais juste que pour préparer ce
procès lee c'est vraiment d'intégrer
pitié même chose aux liftings soit par
exemple au site c'est dans le fond c'est
pour ton cerveau comprennent le
mouvement vraiment bien t'es pas capable
de le faire puis tu peux juste d'y
penser plus de visualiser mots cités
mais quand j'ai commencé le crossfit
jeter qui dit vidéo justement de créer
un jak 2 de nature pour
vraiment mon cerveau 4 qu'est ce que
c'est quoi le mouvement dans une folle
tarif sera en forme exacte exact qui
voit la fin ça devient physique c'est ça
devient intracellulaire biais je pense
que c'est lorsque les gens il s'enferre
je sais que il focalise sur les échecs
et non sur le fond
mais sur ce que des malades ou fake ces
sites se focalise surtout sur la
négative puisque tu peux pas faire pipi
focalise sur ok bon ben qu'est ce que
les gens vont penser de moi puis 60
investissement qu'est ce qui est ma
famille a besoin de moi tu devrais pas
parce il y en a plein un peu comme moi
ce que je faisais là c'est ça tu risques
de même nature et c'était avant
l'arrivée des coachs en ligne des coachs
et one on one il ya là une des premières
au québec a commencé encore le coaching
en ligne
la belge à celle à sydney après ça il y
en avait deux trois qui ont commencé à
faire ce que j'ai commencé à faire mais
bon on est là c'est que toutes nos
stocks de jim des cordes à sauter je
veux partir une bonne de suppléments jeu
les visualiser j'ai partir un an plus
tard puis là on est la seule brandon
canada de suppléments pour femmes fake
c'est tous des choses qui étaient j'ai
visualisé avant puis je m'en fous de ce
que les gens disaient ou fx j'avais un
petit doute dans moi mais au bout du
compte et jj poursuivi avec mes idées il
ya eu beaucoup de doutes par rapport aux
rames et on le fait que tu te lancent en
affaires de gens autour de toi
maintenant deux mois qu'ils ont fait
baisser son risque est ou non c'est plus
moi même je t'accorde thuram a saturé
puis la fin c'est qu'avant moi j'étais
dans le milieu du 3 x moi ce que je t'ai
je faisais du 2 300 milles par année
puis comme je m'en allais là dedans moi
ce que les entraîneurs passent mais
bientôt la jetée comme je suis vraiment
le goût de
tchekhov ok je peu chargé ce que je veux
finalement au bureau que j'avais je
pourrais charge et 75,4 si je voulais
puis je paye un loyer ses thèmes
instabilité mais correct mais acheter
comme il y avait plein de monde mais qui
est également de revenir faire un bout
de cap à québec à chicago à rimouski
c'est partout au québec après notre
émission les cordes c'est vraiment
explosé après ce pays je te promets le
faut que je sois capable d'aller en
ligne si ta classe et lorsque j'ai
commencé les programmes à distance le
challenge puis on regarde me challenge
de ce que c'était avant maintenant ça
aucun rapport aux marques c'était
vraiment à lille mais là on est comme
mon équipe une équipe de graphistes des
vidéos
jeux du monde marketing travaille
directement pour moi est on est vraiment
fourie staff maintenant fixé comme on a
passé de quelque chose de vraiment
amateur à quelque chose de hyper
professionnelle c'est quelque chose
qu'on dit souvent ici le jeu pipi
j'aimerais attendre sur sur les autres
le meilleur conseil je pense à donner à
quelqu'un qui ont un projet en tête
c'est juste de se lancer puis de ne pas
attendre que ce soit parfait parcelle
sera jamais le sera jamais parfait
pierre jamet un moment parfait oui si tu
attends toujours puis moi c'est la même
affaire avec l'industrie 3x jeter comme
je peux avoir l'impression d'avoir
manqué le bateau puis que j'arrive à 30
ans à faut que j'aie manqué quelque
chose qui au niveau de ma sexualité
aussi qu'ici pts agir est une fois king
déviante aujourd'hui parce que j'ai
l'était avant peut-être répète des
affaires comme beckham accueilli par une
famille pigeons par des orgies de combat
tekken c'est des enfants de moi ce que
j'ai vécu des choses que j'avais aviv
c'était pas plat ce moment là qui
aujourd'hui je suis c'était choquant dit
quelqu'un de très gros on dit
ça fait en sorte que ti jjj ça va ça va
lui la perte la peine parce que j'ai pas
manquer le bateau j'ai fait ce que
j'avais envie de faire souvent caustique
quentin idée le meilleur timing pour le
faire c'est le continent sans que ça va
pas mieux marcher dans six mois
c'est une idée hip hop quelqu'un qui a
même dit que toi même temps mais c'est
niaiseux mais regarde la vitrine les
butoirs il valait rien de l'amour y est
du bitcoin 69 60 millions us qui est
prédit le 500 milles pour
vingt-cinq tout de suite en dessus oui
mais moi j'ai acheté
mais si tu regardes le sas avait
augmenté le dise 2023
yassim 250000 après ses 2 mai
2025 qui estime à 500 mètres sauvegarde
soit partout partout partout le lait
les prévisions sont bonnes puis j'ai
beaucoup dans la bourse ou si enfin que
ce serait plus sûr que la crypto
remettez la culture tout le bitcoin bmw
on prête pas acheter une bm a vécu avec
un effectif saisi ça va toujours rester
à à la hausse mais si on regarde avant
la c6 rien acheter ce jeu me rappelle il
en vendait les eaux à la belle province
sur st laurent
coin loin pour jean racheter des
affaires en ligne rouge en faire des
annonces étaient comme ça va les
gars qui sait aujourd'hui fix it attend
trop longtemps tue vraiment qui détecte
le bateau fait de sauter sur l'idée à
une gaufrette parce que l'obstacle le
regretter plus tard
tout 6,7 drive le entrepreneuriale qui
était est ce que le move d'aller
d'un point c'était tout un move
entrepreneuriat c'était quelque chose tu
avais envie de vivre c'était plus un
trip les deux les deux je suis quelqu'un
quand même menacé sexuelle l'amont à
être juillet
mais comme à moi je suis quelqu'un de
très sexualisée et puis pour moi c'était
comme à qui je veux je suis confortable
avec mon corps j'ai pas le goût de faire
un affaire 5 jamais sera une façon que
six mois l'aide de pouvoir me souvenais
pas quelqu'un ou glisser je suis chute
chez l'opposition à tunis pas quelque
chose je le fais je le fais pas jouer le
contre à comme je suis un peu une base
de cette façon là c'est conforme à ce
que la carte à teufen à l'école toute
épreuve
[Rires]
salut luis
nenê comme la balle à l'école puis je me
suis dit je n'ai pas le goût de
travailler à la phase 5 argent 15 cale
dans leur pays j'étais un peu comme
j'avais fini mon monstre d'honneur aux
adieux et puis après ça je travaillais 2
km 4 heures à minuit chez chez rogers
comme ça quand tu es à la pression j'ai
monté un manager après ça j'ai monté aux
ressources humaines j'avais zéro diplôme
la bande c'est parce que je suis
quelqu'un travaillant texte writer
choisi au printemps j'étais capable de
régler les conflits entre les employés
avec les clients avec l'ennemi ont
augmenté je faisais un salaire de 70
mille agents du sapin mais c'était trop
court après depuis le jeu commence à
être intéressés par la pointe puis j'ai
lâché rogers pour aller travailler dans
ce milieu là je me suis dit ils ont
ramené du et je vais essayer de faire le
maximum d'argent puis je veux devenir de
la meilleure là dedans c'est que je suis
prêt mais ça va repartir los angeles me
suis trouvé un agent puis je restais là
bas mais tout ça bientôt à 17 ans quand
j'ai 18 ans je m'envole abbott à 18
heures à 18 heures mais je tiens comme
choisi les photos genre sous sa gorge la
td photo un peu plus osé apprécié dans
le temps c'est québec érotique l'avant
somme
on est bon et préserver
les magazines québécois qui je te dirai
oui je pense que mon premier film je les
fêtes à 19 parce que 18 choses comme il
faut tout sexy un pur souche de
commencer quoi je capable de faire plus
la seconde affaire mon argent je sortir
de l'eau puis je vais aller en
immobilier je vais mettre sur mon cas je
vais être cet été puis je vive mais très
peu mise expérience puis honnêtement je
le regrette pas ça a été vraiment des
expériences au temps fou que genre trash
autant que comme c'est parti playboy
mansion si ça a été vraiment comme une
expérience de vie que je vais m'en
rappeler pour toujours pis pour résister
au temps court que n'importe quoi
laisser ce n'est pas ce n'est pas comme
le monde pense que c'est d'être petit
mais pour moi celle n'était pas supposé
être exploité la donne zéro c'est parce
qu'on est l'image même temps puis
j'imagine que je sais pas exactement
d'où nous vient du team âge-là je sais
pas peut-être que tu pourras me dire si
elle est un peu
et là dedans pour certaines personnes
mettent à l'image la fédé 18 ans qui
déménage à la 100g le piquer leur
encontre nagin la manette crible de la
pente est vraiment glissant de l'autre
bord situent quelque chose qui est vraie
ce une réalité des véhicules avec une
émergence labeur qui ont toute l'élite
happening mais
comme on avait tout la même agent qui
y en as we que si tu cherches un pur
luxe et ça ce que ça n'ait pas marché
car aucune porte personnalité avec une
taille de ses papiers mais personnes qui
meurent année c'est vrai oui c'est moi
qui veulent ramener les choses pour que
quelques bonnes années mais j'ai vu des
filles wascat il prenait de la drogue
il faut aller par leur cinq maps
échéance une maison une morale ce qu'ils
appellent parce que toutes les filles
défilent durable la russie qui mènent
piège est là bas vient aux autres ils
achètent une maison qui donne ce au fur
et à mesure des chambres de six loups
loi la semaine pour le temps qu'ils ont
leurs shoots apprécié repartent qu' il y
en avait une at pascal est une bouteille
de 26 ans le matin ne pas aborder jamais
eu de vote
qui ont beaucoup de bagages
c'est beaucoup beaucoup de bagages puis
qui ont été gravement blessés je pense
que c'est soc c il se voit comme ça
comme des queues se dégrader jacky
semaine lors des premiers dépendance que
lapointe sert à payer ce prix le service
ems et comme il ya des avocats qui
travaillent comme des balles à moi j'en
ai connu l'un des avocats aussi que
c'est des coq et l'épinard est pour se
payer la co qu'utilise pour travailler
plus on se paye de la coupe le
gamin je fais de la pop veut la peau de
travailler plus
mais mettez c'est ça la réalité
factuelle monde coire est tellement dit
pourquoi le corps prête l'avocat qui
fait de la poupe qui va tromper sa femme
qui va voir plein d'escort honda side
c'est sa femme et blessé plus
socialement acceptée versus la fille qui
vahid en pointe qui va utiliser son
corps pour
de l'argent puis peut-être devoir
prendre des dépenses pour moi si on me
vont c'est la même chose c'est jusqu'à
la société le perçoit différemment je
sais pas je pense que là on est encore
un peu de recul on au niveau du
féminisme mais c'est vrai que c'est un
réel problème parce que oui les filles y
rentrer là-dedans pis alors tourner pas
de farce où il ya des primes derrière ce
petit jeu honnêtement c'est pas un
milieu que je conseille à personne en
fait parce que si tu vas là dedans il
faut que tu sois sens pour ça concerne
des les répercussions qui peut avoir
plus tard puis
c'est où tu t'en veux c'est moi j'avais
une porte de sortie je me suis moi
j'attends très prenants gendarmes basse
fait avec moi y'a personne qui vient ici
avec la visualisation que tu parlais
tout à l'heure le dis que tu te fais
savoir rentrer là dedans tu veux savoir
qui voici tant d'années dé diasso est ce
que je suis en ligne puis après ça j'ai
mangé ma porte je sais de 19 à 22 j'ai
fait mon argent je veux mes
investissements je te souhaite pour
étudier jeu tombée enceinte à 24 puis
j'ai pas travailler le gg j'ai fait mes
études puis jetée j'ai étudié en
immobilier puis je faisais mes affaires
je t'en sers profiter ma grossesse
j'avais de l'argent de côté et j'avais
de l'argent qui revenait des loyers
fixes étaient jetés c'était tpiy pour
moi c'était c'était seulement mon goal
puis moi je n'ai jamais que je laissais
sommes affectés parce que j'ai tellement
ouverte puis je veux que ça fasse partie
de mon bagage pour que je puisse éduquer
les gens comme autant comme pour les
filles on est fan pour moi c'est la même
affaire que de la pointe c'est pas parce
que puis je pense à ma maman quand même
temps c'est moins régulariser passe les
gens qui vont s'appeler les filles dont
les fentes à on va si vite et je sais
pas si ces gens là seront testées on le
sait pas mieux si on se fait qu t on ne
sait pas si c'est vraiment
ces points parce que dans le milieu de
trois excepté testé trois fois par
semaine parce que tout quand même
travaillé sur des grosses prod
s'est passé ça c'est pas genre c'est pas
amateur avec ta caméra
il ya des déréglementations puis vous
êtes tester souvent comment ça
fonctionne on était restés trois fois
par semaine puis testés comme tu es jim
dine et mon dieu sait quoi elle mène le
gars qui a joué dans pirates
la cape to cape
town
mais en danse et en même temps je
t'avais thématiques tout les gros n'ont
pu que c'est juste pas quel rôle que je
te comme mon père quand j'avais 18 ans
puis comme avant de tourner avec ces
gueux les gens qui montent chamond une
expédition forêt enchantée tfm deux
autres
j'assistais comme on avait des
productions n'a comme 3 400 migrants
ouais t'as un clin d'oeil c'est un
classique qu'on était car on était ados
on parlait de pirates
si jane ouais ouais j'ai déjà rencontré
ici c'est aussi tout comme je te
remarquer cc comme des célèbres is là
bas fait que c'était c'était vraiment
cool par contre si ça c'est pas pour
tout le monde puis je trouve que autant
que ce soit un non ifrs ou que ça soit
un des photos n'est pas qu'est ce que tu
vas faire ça peut être affecté dans ta
vie avec faut savoir c'est quoi tu veux
faire plus tard fouet dans l'essence de
cause c'est simple si tu sais pas ce que
tu veux faire plus tard et que peut-être
de prendre un moment pour réfléchir deux
fois parce que peut-être que ça va
affecter dans la société et pas encore
rendus là est bon car c'est évolutif au
niveau de l'acceptation du titre mais
aussi c'est que ça va toujours laissé
des traces qui sont permanentes les
trois sites pour tout le temps ça va ça
va être en ligne
courant différence et c'est pour moi
c'est pas quelque chose de négatif c'est
quelque chose au contraire des post-it
j'ai réussi à te faire des conférences
dans les maisons de jeunesse pour des
fugueurs
fait comme des justement par l'étude du
milieu 3 expliqué de parce qu'eux aussi
avaient des filles que j'ai rencontrés
que tous étaient des scores pitié tech
c'est comme
faut faire la sensibilisation parce que
c'est trop accessible sur instagram sait
tout des photos de filles g-strings on
peut quasiment là nuces le tc comme c
est si troublant fait que c'est assez
facile d'abord accès à ce genre
d'informations là quand et adolescentes
le son est assez grave le fait qu'il
faut faire la sensibilisation
c'est le c'est parce que dans tout les
discours entourant c'est là le travail
du sexe dans le fond
que les que les femmes parce qu'ils
veulent avec leur corps c'est vraiment
clé le titre dans l'histoire le sauf que
moi qui compare le son on dirait que
j'ai tout le temps d'un background la
petite fille de 15 ans qui vois-tu une
feuille qui est sûrement les fans ce qui
qui qui fait kiffer un million par année
quasiment le dressay je crois pas ça je
pense qu'elles m'ont il s'est un peu
comme les je sais pas on voudrait que ce
site soit pas de l'argent le oui mais
après c'est le goal qui est ternie de
tous bords les bases des abonnés viva
sabanero il va pas s'abonner habitué à
du pillage par mois est possible fait
que moi je pense que peut-être qu'il ya
un coup d'argent faire mais maintenant
c'est ça sauf que ce soit il faut t'y if
ça paraît pas qu'un quand tu le vois là
dessus quand est ce que tu regardes la
personne à lille c'est comme crime est
rendu au mexique
un voyage payé par je sais pas quelle
personne ou par elle-même avec cet
argent là ça fait rêver mais en même
temps c'est une grosse décision qu'est
ce que tu vois à laisser ceux qui
réussissent plus ceux qui sont connus
maîtrise il y en a pas beaucoup pour
beaucoup c'était une telle demande ton
défi au québec font vraiment beaucoup
d'argent comme ifans il y en a une
poigne il pour combien s'inscrivent
là-dessus justement à en ayant c'est
comme modèle père dans un sens que ça va
marcher comme ceux qui finalement sont
200 pièces par an par mois pour 200
pertes par mois puis leur mère leur
parle plus des piges de serre offre
quand même le cema ses possibilités
c'est ce se saisir moi je pense que pour
beaucoup de gens c'est c'est du rêve qui
vendent les gens suivent les les plus
jeunes ils vont suer puis vont regarder
ça comme tu dis comme des modèles je
pense pas que les gens font autant
d'argent qui disent qu'ils font oui mais
moi j'ai pas de projet moi je vais avec
mon fils et moi je pense que si
différentes tu connais quand même un peu
sur l'ouest can après c'est parce que
j'essaye le christ en pointe on a
commencé à faire j'ai fait un bon
salaire à la primaire commence on le 10
févr
pièce par ça et me fait que si on
s'entend là c'est tout propre toutes
leurs neuf cases par mois précise votre
splits avec on y pense à sa maman pour
ça 50% se pose c'est important je crois
c'est vrai pour cher mais maintenant 20%
plus apprécié et et taxes en sabots vite
une autre affaire aussi que je que je me
demandais l'autre fois parce que étant
quelqu'un qui consommaient de la
pornographie depuis un bon bout on voit
mettons vraiment une rotation un genre
de celle fleuve vraiment paul ont des
producteurs surtout femme le sait les
yeux et je veux dire c'est john ici et
là depuis que j'ai commencé à tuer
lapointe qui est encore long
et les semaines le team est l'homme qui
pratique tous les médias
mais mais on dirait que chez les femmes
il ya vraiment une courbe qui de 2 à 3 1
qui est vraiment rapide le commence par
jour le
savait déjà mais qu'ils commencent par
comme girls girls après ce gars avec go
après ce sexe anal après ce gang bang
après ça le quelque chose d'autre pis la
pression à disparaître cette courbe là
c'est quelque chose qui se parlent dans
le milieu ce qui est tout ce que vous
êtes au courant non mais écoute pour moi
c'était ça ou bien est ce que je me
trompe parce que moi on dirait que j'ai
vu sur le sait on dirait que des fois
j'avais même toit était préféré à ce
moment alors qu'il y avait une courbe
comme ceux qui se faisaient bien mais
il faut passer à autre chose où il ya
martin parce qu'il ya des foyers en
action comme s'ils sont plus capables
sombre intente le sait vraiment demande
en exigeant tu sais pas comme on voit le
succès est sûre cependant 10 heures
d'attentes à tcc vraiment mécanique le
tcc là pour moi c'est ça tu
risques un groupe assez long à ce pack
lincecum ses demandes en effectif
peut-être les gens easton mais il y en a
beaucoup le que ses saillies point des
plus des plus jeunes se soient pis c'est
un truc que je trouve vraiment à six
mois leur accord là je sais pas
l'aspirateur de clara californie je
mettrai ça 21 ans base du borrigo même
ça m'fait kring j'avais j'avais 20 ans
puis m'ont mis comme une sitcom avec une
finition ou un puel avait de la halle
avait vraiment l'air d'avoir 14 ans mais
avait 18 mai dernier au puy pour moi c
sérums c'est tellement si ça peut avoir
de la fille de 14 ans quelqu'un est le
sérum pour toi maintenant est-ce que
c'est l'été au moment où est ce qu'ils
t'ont casté pour jouer au baby gym et
step à halifax et puis tu le fais quand
même mais par des caciques ton contre
foot une facette signes d'embellie ce
tapage one thing to do list taghrid qui
est vrai c'est bon mais quand j'ai vu la
fille de camilla de l'argent mais elle
avait 18 ans mais le berrigaud c'est
quelque chose d'être très très populaire
fête quand comme étant une fille me
trompe pas pour l'instant prêt est fait
et dans pendant six à bella qui a
commencé à la plus vieille la limite
de
mes meilleures flèches et la mode le
fait que je sais plus le ça fait
longtemps jeu plus là bas mais comme le
mail sebaï la mode fait
[Musique]
que ça va ramener à ma chique un gros
coup le monde fait y en a qui viennent y
en a qui rentrent
sécessionnistes comme les acteurs
ligue 1
parce que c'est un bon acteur parce
qu'il ya tellement de gars qui dit ce
qu'il veut faire ce fake arguant qu'un
gorille bon ils vont garder pour
toujours parce que les gens ils s'en
foutent de kotkai a là il veut juste
voir un pénis que ce qui fait que ce qui
fait que mme acteurs et bon ben il faut
que ceux capables de balai sur comment
devenir sur commande le garder on sort
kaman et performant gardée pendant deux
journées de la fin de ma réaction
cependant des zones non irriguées de
france
qui a pris en deux matches il faut quand
même que tu sois capable ces moments nex
à l'époque il était au gagnant
ils viennent d'asthme et
moi je les laissais qui s était un gars
qui rentre et la banque aux deux mois
puis je les miss i'm happy hogan il y
avait m
qui est resté dans ce milieu là vraiment
longtemps même quand on s'est laissé
juste parce qu'ils étaient capables de
performer comme dans les deux trois
premiers sets étaient pas capables il
est allé sur le site de brest un cheveu
de brothers puis t'es pas capable il ya
comme yaya fij et puis même avec des
pilotes ça marche et porn flakes et à la
fin vous tue viennent aussi parce que
c'est bien pas enfin je mâche pas
ses seuls enfants c'est que c'est
tellement loin
tellement loin l'expérience sexuelle
humaine ouais tu parlais quand tu étais
venu sur le podcast sexuelle tu parlais
du fait que des fois vous répétiez des
lignes ne vous répétiez scénario mais
c'est pour que georges plus je comprends
posséder des firmes en fait beaucoup de
films ces foules budget s'est plongée
j'ai même écrit mon problème c'est je
voulais faire une parodie d'out of time
machine fait que j'ai tout écrit mais
l'inpi c'est ici
que j'ai comme tout autour de 7000 et
puis j'ai dit ah comme tout les gars
c'est ce que vous allez dire c'est juste
drôle parce que c'est quand même un peu
ton esprit créatif qui rendra petite
équipe et moi je veux que tu as le gâter
sa phase te l'a pas fait tess c'est
quand même drôle puis je pense qu'ils
m'ont qui aime vraiment ça va la faire
sonner les crocs et par les associations
mais c'était tout le temps c'est
aberrant qu elle faisait pas de fille tu
as choisi beaucoup beaucoup dit fisher
est ce que font des fautes écoute ce
petit jeu comme crime mais aussi celle
de brut à des
rôles comiques font répéter pied répétés
puis répéter jusqu'à tactile là parce
que tu sais c'est tout le même genre de
combat ce même le monde qui sont dans
les castings pour les films normaux
c'est tout réalisme dans les mondes
qu'il ya du monde qui est
beaucoup beaucoup de crossover avec ses
copains on regarde maintenant comme
l'annonçait
qui de recrutement qui
me met en prison
à la fête des fleurs à
lala com arrive après
comme tout fini
qui lors de la fête des futures étaient
partout les
mêmes rôles qu'ils vont jouer le
l'italien aussi le
côtoyer
chili me pose
pas car
tu imagines que c'est quelque chose
c'est quelque chose qui existe lorsque
tout est fréquent comme des débordements
sur des ouais j'ai vu des filles parties
non mais lui comme non lui s'est fait
accuser de
violer une fille je pense aux femmes
si c'est un show tu dis qu'ils n'ont
lesieu et 9 qui continue jocelyne
agression et fait passer par la france
parce que c'est leur job fait qu'il
revienne c'est moi j'étais sur l'a7 à
james haskell a fait partir à tapis
avant d'en prendre passé comme moi
j'étais plus dans le
décor est
qu'il n'y avait pas le
soin à la
fiction comme à l'aise avec ça
si je regarde ma part je fais comme ça
pas d'estibeaux sein de centres
mais puis mais il ya dessus du me
tue du plaisir sur les 7 ou bien c'est
juste du travail tu sais où 26 ans pour
sa de l'acting parce que la chine reste
un moment
tu aimes ton travail oit je sais pas
comment maga genre travail à chaque
match mais même si tu es content d'aller
shooter puis j'imagine que des fouilles
certaines sont des acteurs keith et plus
fun que l'autre oui ça m'est arrivé une
fois que sur mons est en fait que
j'avais jamais dirigé une bonne job puis
j'avais vraiment le trac toi qui t'es
fou le contenu je mets un peu plus c'est
quoi son nom entre cueilli était
vraiment connu mettait un peu fraîche et
puis il passa sa vie un peu les poètes
et y étaient toutes à soissons celle
picard n'était pas de lui et c'était
vraiment comment des acteurs y mettez
moi comme ça paraît
c'est moi qui ai alors fait que cgt
comme pour que le femi policiers sinon
il faut que tout ça ils vont pas me
donner un nom j'ai quand même réussi à
comme dirigé des films avec je t'aime je
te contente quand même fait que c'est
juste une fois mais ce nom que les
majorités de star c'était ben correct
mais j'imagine qu'il ya des preuves tout
était tombé dans les bonnes bottes de
produits un jeune fille tout en un de
wild de deux boîtes de prod un peu plus
sans - baysse pour sauter comme soit tu
fais de la bonne façon et tu t'en vas
chercher aux bonnes places où tu fais
pas en tout nés puis comme je dis c'est
pas un métier que je suggère à personne
juste parce que je pense pas que des
gens ont la force mentale je pense que
c'est une faible minorité de personnes
qui ont cette force mentale pour faire
mouiller pas grand-chose qui maintient
en vie mais vraiment moche ça touche pas
à ma famille qui me servent à rien y'a
rien qui me dérange vraiment c'est comme
je pense que la majorité des gens sont
beaucoup plus sensibles qui peut-être
que tu es ils vont pas avoir la capacité
mentale pour pouvoir faire ce genre de
choses là où avant la compréhension des
répercussions que sa voix [ __ ] c'est
pas comme je sais pas pour tout le monde
puis c'est pas un milieu facile puis
c'est un choix fallait parce que je
n'imagine que au delà des tournages fait
de la job en tant que tel il tout en
restant tout un lifestyle qui vient avec
le tir imagine que tu dois avoir quand
même de la drogue qui circule ouais
départ type d affaire que
les gens faisaient énormément de drogue
autant que les gueux que l'effet
marine si beaucoup de la coke dans ce
cd ouais ouais texte pour s'écharper
jamais cherché partout les doivent vidéo
a viré calmes et on les fait pas
maintenant les
jeux tel aviv after
il y avait une danseuse qui me draguer
je me serais retrouvé dans une chambre
d'hôtel avec jean peine monde qui
pourrait
rester comme c'était quelque chose mais
c'est leur vie un métier mettons playboy
mansion bensaleh vous aussi pissarev
jusqu'à minuit le midi lendemain les
gens pourront porter ces messages
étaient comme je t'ai pas capable de
chez par contre mon agenda fuchs il ya
il faut que tu fasses du bio au piment
de tafas parce que sinon ils vont pas te
mettre sur tel peach up étaient des
features et fois qu'une payant ces
genres dix mille piastres faire un futur
fait qu'il faut que tu sois capable de
rencontrer les directeurs péter
rencontrer dit bel antonio raffineur il
en est allé rencontrer c'est tout du
meilleur texte ici c'est super super
importante est-ce que des fois dans ce
pays or l'oeil des espèces de futurs
encore le directeur mai
comme si tu le si tu veux pas son film
faut que tu le soutier toute affaire de
manip a cependant tout ça reste
professionnel ça reste professionnel
j'ai jamais eu d'expérience alors est-ce
que piano piano paul toi dans nos poches
j'en ai pas eu peut-être qu'il y en a
mais ça mais comme j'aime et je sais sur
mac et des filles qui font la passe
qu'il va d'abord être entendu parler de
poche du son nom j'ai fonctionné car tu
parles de cette période là puis je te
demande les parties plis tournage tout
une certaine nostalgie gens c'est comme
des bons souvenirs ou c'est comme que
c'est fait pire on passe à autre chose
j'ai pas quelqu'un qui reste dans le
passé j'ai quelqu'un qui est comme j'ai
vécu mon passé puis ça peut être ce
téléphone mais je focalise sur mon
avenir tout le temps c'est comme quand
que je faisais ça je focalisais sûrement
sur ce que je voulais pas dans deux
heures fait que je vois quelqu'un qui
veut gagner dans le passé est ici c'est
fait c'est fini puis ça fait partie de
ma vie bah ça fait plus partie de ma vie
maintenant fox pour ceux qui trichent
pas comme prix là dedans pis je
changerai jamais ma vie que j'ai
aujourd'hui pour seul jamais jamais je
n'aurais plus jamais faire ça stage le
non non non puis tout te tue t ce
qu'auteurs qui du jour au lendemain tu
as fait bastonner
ouais j'ai vu comme ben arfa saha qu'un
que j'ai rencontré mon chemin j'ai fait
pas 2 300 puis après ça je crains que je
suis revenu ici j'ai juste aller direct
à l'école puisque fini qui fonctionne
comme l'élément déclencheur du non en
fait cette demande à l'étudiant
l'immobilier mais peut-être que c'est
quelqu'un que je les rencontre et ben
c'est soit que lui déménageant qu'ali
ben moi je m'en venais ici pyjama
lui et ses babouches après que je suis
comme partie à montréal parce que lui
démarrait sa business puis je m'ennuie
un peu quand même mais ça faisait
longtemps j'étais parti mais je voyage
depuis j'ai 16 ans
avant cgt uk j'ai opté à londres j'avais
mon ex kittel a beau s'appeler dosage
célèbre ses trois ans et cinq ans que je
n'ai plus vraiment ici je ramenais juste
un peu de temps en temps avec je
m'ennuyais tchimou le grand tom vorias
way
comment est ce que parce que tu es aussi
tu as été un couple aussi pendant que tu
étais dans le monde lapointe comment est
ce que ta relation avec la sexualité
versus l'amour et va évoluer avec le
temps ce que maintenant tout est ce que
j'imagine qu'à ce moment là tu n'as pas
le choix elle est capable de le
dissocier parce que ça fait partie
prenante de ton emploi mais est-ce que
tu est encore capable de le faire
maintenant où est ce que le site devenu
quelque chose qui vraiment
en communion mettons balle à ses succès
comme en union mais avant j'étais
vraiment capable de séparer ce qui m'a
tant que je serais si le batteur
aujourd'hui je serais capable dans une
relation sans tomber en amour la
personne c'est pour moi ces six titres
par une attirance physique sans
nécessairement être en amour la personne
c'est pour moi c'est comme si pour
séparer les deux choses puis je pense
que tu avoir une intimité sexuelle puis
amour heures c'est quelque chose de
vraiment fort pis c'est c'est quelque
chose qui va en union mais tu es capable
je serai capable d'abord les deux
séparés aussi ok je retournerai dans ce
milieu là mais comme ça ferait comme un
jeu s'est peu infernal on ne s'en
lassera n'importe quoi les jeux seraient
capables comme séparer les deux mais
attirer du monde terrific attitude ce
que j'avais qu'une fois puis tombe en
amour a que toi tu y en a beaucoup c'est
seul puits ou d'ego city avait plus que
c'est ce que j'avais lu 20 pays et ex
non-stop comme un full
vexé comme c'est peut-être les étés les
règles claires maintenant qu'ils sont
pas capables de faire ce peut être pour
moi je pense que c'est quand même une
bonne chose de pouvoir ceux ci les deux
quand avec une sexualité aussi intense
que sur le tir avec les gipsy
tout ce que ça implique ci dessus
difficile de revenir la sexualité
normale mais non mais non non non parce
que je me vois vraiment mal par ce lait
entre le chômage approche stratégique a
du mal d'altitude au lit
mais quand même avant si je suis rentré
dans le milieu là j'étais quelqu'un
encore très sexuel mais j'étais comme
une hippie des années 70 cela on était
comme genre plein d'amis puis on faisait
plein de porter des partouzes et wever
avant de rentrer dans ce genre a déjà
tant le nom genre 18 points 18 mai comme
des enfants ouais mais comme avec genre
mon job c'est moi j'ai toujours et
encore je sais pas pourquoi mais j'ai
toujours été vraiment encore quelqu'un
mais comme je reste un
char pas avec n'importe qui pique quand
je rate à quelqu'un c'est parce que
c'est la bonne personne une personne à
ce moment j'ai fait comme de jean 16 à
18 ans j'étais nom de 15 à 18 j'étais en
coop et après ça j'ai rencontré un gars
de 9 jusqu'à 23 je restais avec on s'est
mariés uk
pilon parce qu'un falcon restant
semblables fait que l'on s'y déversaient
qu'un cas je raconterai à l'hippisme ans
après j'ai rencontré halifax et comme
c'est ici des choses parce que je comme
chichi on est un peu comme un couple
ouvert à 20 mais je m'aime vraiment mal
être ça dans ma vie familiale que j'ai
aujourd'hui comme suit pas la même place
où même les mêmes mindset que j'étais à
cette époque là parce que c'est ce que
les enfants un rôle à jouer là-dedans
c'est comme un tuning pointe de genre
style de vie ou pas nous sommes au oui
c'est ça que c'est une adaptation mais
aucun aucun rapport avec att la
sexualité bas c'est ça qui est un peu
comme quand c'est par amour quand tu
veux ou tu veux les enfants laissés
calmette et c'est ton l'oeil
les affaires tu veux pas qu'ils voiture
non c'est un fait sic c'est plus
difficile mais comme ça ça n'impacte pas
mes choix que je fais aujourd'hui
puis le on parle tantôt de kanté quatre
grades de projeté à l'avant est ce que
dans est ce que tu es capable de vivre
ce moment là quand même où tu étais tout
le temps
dans le futur tout le temps moi mon plan
c'est ce c'est là je veux aller parce
que j'imagine qu'il y en a qui skie qui
rendent la dap qu'elle s'est quand même
un doute pas de plan vraiment tu fais
tout ça chaque année du fait de l'argent
puis continuez continuez plus une
première chose pu s'éjecter c'est que tu
étais là dedans depuis dix ans mais
après c'est plus qu'est ce que tu vas
parler enroulement approcher 30 ans ou
qui était
la réalité fait de mettre de côté
tactile y en a beaucoup laissé seul ses
six c'est vraiment ça c'est j'ai des
amis encore aujourd'hui que je vois là
dans pi est approché 40 ans un péché
comme tes potes années montrent que je
t'aime ouais t'as encore nous a mis un
milieu j'entends quand du contact
well as angeles - taxi ce n'est pas moi
je sais pas si je le vois ses filets qui
ont pris un mode de vie sain et là
qu'elles sont toutes en supporter sa
brosse à lundi soit hors jeu comme un si
c'est accepté parce que ça peut devenir
très très très rapidement toxiques qu
moche comme tellement à l'opposé
seulement grands noms je sens ma
méditation matin mais koch la méditation
oui je prends mes est d'abord le soir et
j'écoute des artistes et je suis
vraiment grano le cas mais je mange bio
c'est vraiment que
comme je vois ça comme un jeu tellement
contente depuis est dans son métier est
ce que le fait de l'avoir vu de l'avoir
vécu un pur pis tout à fait doublement
comprendre l'importance d'un mode de vie
sain et puis que ce soit mais c'est pour
ça que tu sais je suis encore vraiment
extrêmement dans ma façon d'être
aujourd'hui parce que je n'ai quand même
pas oui peut-être pas la plus le port
d'une non je ne peux plus supporter mais
je dois quand même supporter plus
qu'aujourd'hui ses matons et moi sortir
du jeudi au dimanche je sais comment
supporter il comparativement du monde la
boot va être comme ça à oujda
comparativement à jean mobutu
[Rires]
intense quand même la pythie jugement je
n'ai pas trop comment je buvais quand
même là que les choses aient pas
tellement attention et
c'est je me couchais vraiment tort fait
que c'est tous des choses qui ont fait
que je me sentais vraiment pas bien
j'étais je faisais faux l'inflammation
et si j'avais plusieurs problèmes de
santé fait qu en étudiant mais aussi en
apprenant mon métier puis à voir à quel
point tu capable de changer ma vie mais
aussi la vie des autres je te promènes
pourquoi j'ai vécu le même effet que je
pense par loties pour pour apprendre que
ceux-ci mama comme ça c'est ma passion
c'est ce que je veux faire c'est ce que
je veux montrer aux gens ce que je veux
aider les gens vraiment optimisé leur
santé pas ce moment ne sont vraiment pas
en santé c'est grave à quel point les
gens le sentent et puis les gens savent
même pas qu'ils sont pendantes et quand
une cliente qui viennent voir que dix
jeux optimisés ma santé
c'est parce que sa part ce jeudi
l'entraînement lamentations mais
j'imagine que tout un éventail de
solutions je me devais absolument
absolument mais c'est sûr c'est dans
l'alimentation c'est 80% à une invasion
fait qu'on commence tranquillement assis
à évaluer si c'est quoi ces six modes
son mode de vie qu'est ce qu'un manjak
alors casse-cou chez stella des
problèmes crâne et que c'est quoi son
historique médical ce qu'ils y ont des
problèmes de diabète dans fin mai
à ce qui est régulière je crois que le
cycle hormonal donc le cycle menstruel
ça va affecter la rétention d'eau ça va
affecter l'inflammation ça va ça va
aussi affecter ce que la personne veut
mieux digérer assimilés comme nourriture
durant cette période le fait qu'une
panoplie de choses qui font en sorte que
bombay moi je veux coacher la cliente de
telle façon puis même quand jenson
challenge c'est pas comme tu achètes un
pdf été lancé dans le vide on a des live
gd nature ou de notre famille c'est
s'agit des médecins qui sont quand même
assez holistique pour des médecins comme
trop cheap il est le pilote mais
vraiment plus holistique qui vont
prendre et l'alimentation saine on lui
met une petite boule
fait quand on travaille avec des
professionnels qui veulent aller à la
problèmes aux problèmes source qui est
souvent cessé dans la nourriture fout de
ce magazine je le dis toujours ce que tu
manges c'est ce que tu es si tu manges
transformer piketty de suprendre saut
depuis que tu fais pas ça peut être
aussi nié ce que quelqu'un qui mange des
yeux huit fois par jour l'espace pas bon
le fait que c'est des choses que les
gens ne savent pas que c'est pas bon
pour la santé mentale à sa cause
l'inflammation systémique qui ça peut
causer td dictée cellules cancéreuses il
ya plein d'affaires au niveau de la
santé que ce rapport a mis à part c'est
la perte de groupe laprise hamas et puis
toi dans le fond c'est ces formations
lors de fêtes des formations en
naturopathie le che et titans dans la
trousse et 5 information je rendis à ma
deuxième année le java parce que j'ai
d'une expérience adam fait que j'ai
sûrement finir comme l'année prochaine
mais comme quelqu'un qui remarque la
danse et cinq ans sinon si j'ai des
envies des formations comme en prenant
privé en biomécanique ans willow special
guest prix poste n'a pas été comme une
de mes premières j'étais allé chercher
fait que la nature au mais c'est souvent
les gens ils focalisent trop sur la
perte de groupe i la prise de masse qui
comprennent pas tout le système derrière
c'est ce que tu manges keys qui va aussi
impactés au 8a forme physique à l'oeil
mais à l'intérieur le team n moi je fais
de la compétition lambicchi ming est
classé dans l'est dans les tops troll du
québec qui comme et coach était pas plus
en santé intérieur mon objectif qui
était était dégueulasse ma peau était
dégueulasse je dormais tout le temps je
t'ai blanc comme un droit mais pourtant
quand que tu me prenant pour toi qu'un
boss prétendent je te découper sur 1,8
pack avec des quads des façades grossman
était comme preuve c'est tellement c'est
un ebook est hypocrite je trouve comme
le monde la santé c'est pour ça que je
veux montrer les gens comme c'est ben
beau avoir un 8 acmé cm dans les tpo ben
ça vaut ce que ça vaut rien ton
extérieur savons absolument rien c'est
chez compaq en souffrance ou pas de 400
en or justement juste le sont pas c'est
une personnalité c'est toujours seul
discours jugé adéquat à l'heure c'est
pas un indicatif
juste sur site et en santé ou non un
ticket pour la faune en santé mais
justement à l'intérieur beaucoup sa
santé mentale
cavalaire pitre le couvrir de courir des
marathons qui ont pas fait nord de sport
qui ont une bonne génétique je sais
qu'il ya vraiment juste une bonne
génétique ou caissons sont jack et csi
stéroïdes et on la foule en santé on
sait que leurs enzymes de foi sont pas
bons on sait qu'ils vont peut-être
financer les alizés comme mais tu la
regardes tes quant à lui est fort il est
en santé il mange plus que
voulez-vous que les sauces et ce pour ta
santé mentale c'est pas bon pour moi
c'était la pierre asperges à temps le
matin
comme un cauchemar métier choisi le
basket est comme pour moi ce tient
encore atteint c'est un défi que je
voulais faire
classer première fois quand ces
problèmes parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
monde qui était suspect puis mon style
si je n'étais pas donc j'ai comme je
t'ai camille musculeux comparé au fait
t'es que j'ai comme classé dans le top
trois au moins la troisième but quand on
provincial fait que quand même contente
mais je les fais depuis quand même le
monde commente future tournée jeter
comme je te quand même pas bien dans ma
peau comme acheter mais bon après si je
déconne mais fallait que j'y mets temps
de passer à la troisième à la première
qui mettons toutes les sacrifices mais
l'effort qui sera demandé ces normes le
train dont justement avec jean philippe
bouty qu'on ne reçut le lot il parlait
du principe du du 80 20 nautiques et le
dernier vingt pour cent de les chercher
pour te rendre à 100% de quelque chose
années 80 pour cent de l'effort c'était
se prend 4,1 pour cent de l'effort au
pit c'est ça il fallait que tu continues
de manger du tilapia l'aspergé
c'est ma façon d'être comme j'écris un
livre le team am à équilibrer famille
handal antibes c'est tout des recettes
santé bas je veux montrer aux gens qu'on
peut manger super santé puis avoir des
résultats possibles le cas
malheureusement ils sont restés jacques
heleven qui pèse dans le projet mais
comme c'est bien un titre bien en shape
le piège bien en santé lors du transport
des trucs sont bons des desserts à des
déjeuners copirep s'est dit prêt à
manger des patates blanche tu le sais
c'est pas une potentielle de monde le
sait cet acte et les gens sont comme
avant que leurs mentalité des cas mange
pas s'ils mangent pas sa quête aussi été
comme les jeunes étaient menacés c'est
tellement compliqué pour rien quand
c'est ça devrait pas l'être puis moi je
suis je compare toujours sa com a autant
les hommes de cro magnon qu'est ce
qu'ils mangeaient des fruits il ya les
chasser qui mangeaient du gazon et des
légumes c'était simple c'est pourquoi
quand on va consommer des aliments
transformés la piété raffiné ddd des
quantités d'aidés viande pitof
inimaginable c'est comme ça mais mein
blonde sait à quel point que les gens
savent pas comment bien manger quand
kessel et 2 1 a publié des fac haute
savoie je rentre je pense que c'est
important de le dire et le public et
certains aliments gevrier c'est rock est
une occasion et une bonne dit que c'est
une bonne idée mais temps de boire du
coca au niveau de la santé
recommande et que tu devrais
quatre semaines j'étais à dessiner avec
mes enfants qui avaient une maman qui a
donné du coq un bébé y avait pas plus
que six mois dans le biberon et l indice
coca cola puis à taper dans le dos pour
faire un retrait quotidien mouvementé
thatcher du coca cola six mois ouais non
mais ça y est il ya une affaire
d'éducation puis je pense qu'aux states
le problème est encore plus difficile
c'est vraiment - ouais vraiment baisse
tout et tout est plus gros et il s'est
banalisé tu t'en vas tu t'en vas te
faire vacciner pour la corrida d'honneur
guy télécom
c'est que je comprends pas la logique
derrière celles fixées c'est quand même
assez intense à quel point qui font la
propagande des macbook mais aussi les
compagnies pharmaceutiques sont
tellement gros labos qui veulent pas que
les gens ce n'est pas payant les gens en
santé c'est les gens sont en santé et
ont plus d'argent mais compagnies
pharmaceutiques qui y font pitch
l'accession que les gens le plus qui
sont ces pilules c'est plus payant et
j'ai un bon dieu sait quoi devenir accro
jamais une bonne bourre de coco quand
j'ai quand j'ai essayé de faire le 80 km
d'ultramarathon de bronze semaines après
mon marathon puis j'ai passé à auto km
56 km puis quand j'arrivais dans la
tente de premiers soins ils m'ont cru
sur le dos puis il ya une fille qui m'a
mené par le co qui a fait un
pas sans pain de sucre
ça aurait pu être autre chose que du
coccyx aurait pu être n'importe quoi
avec genre des rapides
parce qu'il ya tellement de temps que ça
te ramène pas mal plus
qui fait quoi dans certains cas
mais je les profits ni le type il y en a
qui faisait le 160 le titre a encore une
fois
je marche 10 km
c'est bon tu disais tantôt que la
corrida vraiment propulsé tt affaire le
15 août on a découvert une fille sur
youtube des budgets au début du
confinement le premier confinement de
l'ex appelé grooming ananas ces genres
des vidéos déjà
henning 30 minutes sur youtube qu'un
conte nokia qu'on le découvrira l'avait
genre 24 mille abonnés sur youtube que
la dernière fois que j'ai regardé ça
fait longtemps là doit d'être pas mal
blood curseur est commandée à 450 mais
l'entente avec quelques mois tous
avaient explosé aussi pendant la web
belges viennent partir la chaîne youtube
puis j'ai encore le gîte à m'en occuper
quelques jours j'essaye de comme manager
pinin et plus encore en monétique
beaucoup d'implication pinède de travail
fait que c'est comme ça mon magasin je
le fais plus molle et fun mais pour ça
fait aussi tout gros sur le reste tout
est connecté c'est ça mais comme je mets
pas des vidéos sur youtube des clients
que
et faites les tchatches allen sont
factuels meilhon comme les vidéos
privées sur youtube fait que les gens y
ont accès à des vidéos enregistrées de
mettre 30 40 minutes peu importe le
programme cachette puis le dur lakovic
j'étais un des premiers ajustements à
partir des live arcarde parce qu'on est
toutes des groupes facebook privé ou est
ce qu'on fait est là parce que moi je
réponds à toutes les questions des
filles qui le justement je me suis dit
ben t'as qu'a fait mon mandat maison
j'ai pris mes keane j'ai émis en l'air
jeudi gars vous allez faire les
challenge à tous les matins vous avez
parlé live arcade pour les huit
prochaines salle est un qui sait un
écho s'astiquer on est encore là dedans
pied japon encore l'élève puis ça
explose à virer dieu tu as encore un
taux de participation aussi grand que
pendant que vous allez ça pour ça avec
eux c'est resté dans l'habitude des jeux
là les gens là ils veulent rien dans
l'autre sens comme si je mets pas de
live oublie c'est bon il va être
vraiment fort chez les pauvres et
manquent été le fait que 1000 employés
ont dit nos jobs que j'ai quand même
crié des nouveaux postes quand même pour
mes entraîneurs privés qui faisaient du
yo-yo non loin de coaching à mon jean
mais l'iphone d'ilife et qui ont un
revenu un autre salaire de plus de cela
il ya une demande les filles veulent
vraiment se qui se sont attachés au
coach moi j'ai pas le temps de parler là
bas tous les matins magie des meetings
les enfants des cités mon horaire et
comme intense mais mais mais quand tu
chance ils ont les mêmes valeurs ils ont
été coachés par mois je leur ai dit
comment tout faire comme à paris au fait
c'est quoi mais balma business vraiment
ccc quoi l'image que je me projeter puis
ils font ça comme des pros puis les gens
ont confiance dans les entraîneurs que
j'embauche fait que je quand même
vraiment contente que ça se prend bien
mais c'est pas tout à moins qu'ils aient
besoin d'un club basque un moment donné
ces traitements anti de cordée live à
tous les matins pied c'est pendant un an
tant de si seulement ça va faire un an
bell est un ennemi puis mamés coach
français depuis un an et demi maintenant
c'est vraiment autre j'imagine que ça
donne quand même un bon sentiment de
peut-être fierté ce qui fait pas suffire
tc le bon mot le mais de savoir que tu
as changé l'habitude de les habitudes de
vie de toutes ces personnes là qui à
chaque matin maintenant font du sport
qui en aurait pas nécessairement fait
sinon le seul à être gratifiant quand
même
man pitt mais je suis quelqu'un qui fait
beaucoup d'événements fake je fais des
bouts de 40 jeux rencontrer les faits ou
souvent admettons pour mais peu mes
campagnes publicitaires je vais aller
chercher mes clientes à moi pour venir
c'est ben beau que moi je souhaite
tendance c'est pas mon image que je me
bats et les réalisations des mes
clientes ces millions qui sont sur un
pied d'estale moi c'est n'importe qui
capable de ce coach et piètre sacoche
mais de pouvoir coacher les gens c'est
une autre game fait que moi de pouvoir
prendre ma cliente est leur montrer au
monde pas comme vous pouvez aussi
réussir comme earth et comme tout un
honneur pour moi puis c'est si ces
foules géo 30000 clientes à travers le
canada
ils ont ça va ensemble en europe ou si
j'ai des clientes en france donc on va
commencer à pousser aussi en france tout
comme si c'est fou à quel point qu'on
peut aider des gens c'est débile
les prix de qualité dans le top 10 le
canada c'était sur la croissance en
trois hommes étant là ça ressemble à
quoi les croissances en trois ans
maintenant en termes de chapeau 2 2 le
chiffre d'affaires
va être vraiment une grosse équipe vous
n'êtes pas bien mais tout le temps l on
est rendu 25 employés qui on a comme un
être network évaluation des besoins sont
au dessus des 10 millions fait que quand
même assez contente là dessus
mais abbas et que même si on y va on y
va lui à plus de 10 millions serait ce
que je pourrai jamais dans ma besace
parce que je suis maintenant c'est vrai
que c'est l'évaluation on s'en fout un
peu fait ça c'est ça la passe et ça
c'est qu'est-ce que je dois avec le tfc
comme à ton âge et mon espace bien moi
je pourrais le banc mais comme si il y
aura peu mais pas la même valeur si je
serai pas la tête d'affiché est factice
c'est comme si à partie un peu de ton
brent fonctionne parce que je sais aussi
basse avec un bal des suppléments
c'était ça là on est en rien tout tuerie
brandi parce qu'on exploit malheur boyle
- on a signé avec les ballets menchov en
floride fait que l'on va tout exporter
nos supplément en floride où batman shop
l'on commencé à exporter aussi ailleurs
au canada avec celle de la boot votre
moyen ceux ci ou celle qui était connue
ici mes connaissances
exact que je veux vraiment me dissocier
de la branche veux pas que les gens
disent à
une pose une question sur les protéines
texte
mahmoudi aiment la page professionnelle
on se demande bien mais créé pour tout
ça va tu sois plus elle quand même - cl
m comme tout à fait la réponse parce que
dans le fond le branding comme c'était
vraiment francophone s'est écrite en
protéines en français mépris en anglais
avec les oreilles protein avec protéines
en france est en beau fixe y ont fait
dans les normes depuis sa langue
française mais comme on est quand même
capable de penser cinq salles impacte
négativement la brane l'heure où il est
même possible
qu'il y en a comme tout a changé le lait
des sites cap ça a été vraiment à l'onl
et on travaille là-dessus depuis le mois
de février
on est beaucoup skié mais on a quand
même vous avez produit 30 30 points
juste à piles j'attends qu'on me donne
plein pour trois nouveaux produits c'est
l'hommage et puisque tu viens de dire le
6 mai poser des questions si on a eu
cette conversation luv le six mois je
n'aurai aucune du christ parle mais j'ai
tout de faire
c'est incroyablement long c'est
incroyablement chien anticipe ça coûte
cher biot délit puni pub c'est en plus
le avant je m'appelle quand que j'ai
commencé à chercher tout mais une paix
engagé en 5 ans et 6 mois mais là c'est
quand même un numéro produits naturels
pour ce qui est des codes pour être
approuvée passe qui agit par santé
canada j'ai vu deux mondes qui ont des
produits plus qu'un petit sur un pnj que
le produit pour les pnj comme à québec
c'est illégal sur les tablettes du monte
cassino
quand même il y en a quand même pas mal
parce qu'ils ont peur surtout dans
surtout dans les chaînes un petit peu
plus alternative le team et on chez jean
coutu laisse pas rentrer des produits
qui n'ont pas aimé mais dans des chaînes
plus alternatives des magasins une santé
c'est
quelque chose qui ne peut pas couvrir
sur les assurances la pitié en même
temps tu sais pas qu'est ce qu'il ya
dedans moi je suis heureux mais on a une
énergie s'est passé qui va peu
manufacturier thé produit mais on est
dans le plus le plus violent du québec
le yellow depuis
79 familial puis aujourd'hui on me
produis mes fonds si les produits de
plaudren vraiment connu québécoise
become sont vraiment sur la coche le pis
c'est tout comme vraiment le goût de
manufacture practice et sont vraiment le
jumpy et libéraux sur le feu comme ils
font tout les tests c'est vraiment si si
c'est vraiment une bonne business pas
que je suis comme vraiment rassuré le
sait c'est le moins comme ça je
m'entraînais j'allais chercher des
produits phyto comme on dirait que j'ai
pas confiance parce que j'ai chialé
l'acide citrique d'entre eux il faut le
soutien dans tous les genres foule
record du genre dans les protéines haïti
stanley et iso finalement c'est de la
white et comme à quillan pour le money
c'est juste du marketing qui font comme
une 6 s'était tué en béton le 3-1 le jeu
vraiment pas nommé personne mais tu
rends dans un magasin pis ces tablettes
ce n'est que du marketing ce n'est que
seul jean luc roux et jean raimbault de
la boîte c'est comme un affaire d'aucune
échéance
c'est
fake c'est vraiment ce que tu dis ce qui
est de danser mais ceux-là c'est quelque
chose que mes produits je vous avoue
c'est pas la chose qui paye le plus
parce que je suis vraiment exigeante
avec l'épreuve avec les ingrédients que
je meurs le stévia o'barry ça coûte pas
plus cher que du sucralose mais je
refuse de mettre du créa dans mes
produits ça peut-être moins goûter sucré
mais mon but c'est d'apprendre aux
clientes que du sucralose ces dames 1
c'est pas bon pour ta santé puis tu t'es
krivine kate avec un dimanche et a
abordé kit kat vont rester parce que tu
le fait de diminuer la laiterie du coran
l'est dans tes habitudes de ville c'est
super important le de poids bien choisir
ce que tu prends comme produit de santé
naturel pas si facilement côté nature et
progrès coûts produits de santé naturels
que c'est notamment sentir que je
rencontre a vu le jour exact et où un
stage band the year fruits mais comme il
ya plein de fleurs de danse est fixée il
faut vraiment bien regarder effects pour
ce que tu es ma brève comme toutes les
balles et menchov j'ai tout envoyé mes
produits ont testé fallait que j'arrête
tout ce qui est à part à pied regarder
font des tests 8e sont vraiment exigeant
aux states fait que c'est des choses
comme ça où est ce que je comme c'est
important le quai mes valeurs ils
restent fermes puis que je vends pas de
la croix parce que je serais pas rentré
d'emprunt de magasins comme ça serait
pas bien avec ce personnage aussi le nom
de promouvoir la santé et un mode de vie
sain et puis vendredi quelque chose qui
est un peu c'est certain que c'est quand
même
si comme il s'appelait marie condos le
faisais je
faisais une série où est-ce qu'il
fallait que tu t'es comme clean et toute
ton garde-robe le fait que j'aie
remettons tout le linge que tu portais
pu que tu le donnes et playstation
désencombrer sa maison plus appréciés
comme la série a eu un succès énorme sur
netflix plat après ce halo vert un shop
en ligne ou est ce qu'avant des décos
seul un quart des bibelots vise à faire
le flexi joachim qui me tue mme d'idées
dans le désencombrement c'est bon un peu
souvent des cheats le tct pop en tout
avec avec l'idée même de pourquoi elle
existe dans le fond
un enfant a plaidé du recycl'art ouais
c'est ça
tu parlais tantôt que tu voyais tout le
temps ta vie devant toi qu'est-ce qui
est devant toi maintenant émettant à
partir de lille
plage de costa rica est tombé en amour
avec la place
aux familles
je m'achetais à une propriété au cast
away le pari de dole charpy tu allais
faire un peu de visites de place non
c'est la première que j'allais fait
qu'on est allé juste à la fois tuner
arena le fait qu'on est comme aller plus
dans la jungle parce que moi j'ai des
propriétés au mexique j'en ai quand même
tout le pionner h pour huawei en tout
les 2 carmen mais tu fais du hard
urbaine de toulouse et en faire mon
combat il prend 2023 qui j'ai acheté un
terrain dans l'est pas c'est ma maison
tu es censé être prêtes mais mexicaine
times et deux ans plus tard fait là
évidemment ma maison va être prêts dans
un an et demi cela les jardins terrain
les cheveux avec des architectes ont
bâti ma maison ça va être comme ma
maison mais je vais sûrement la maetur
airbnb je vais voir comment je me sens
mais comme je suis en train de la faire
à mon goût puis le condo c'est vraiment
comme sur la bocca paella dans toulouse
dans la zone hôtelière puis on va pas
durer bien habillé avec ça
puis je te demande à moins que mexique -
le but le cid investir le plus que je
pleure puis doit être comme moi tant que
je prends ma retraite c'est d'abord
comme prennent blocs hors des maisons
partout de abords des maisons partout
puis dire eh bien oui c'est vraiment
payant les maisons au mexique que ça se
loue 1500 pièces en huit mois la maison
combats sont basses contruire 6 maisons
minimum seul oui mais la nuit
ouais parce que c'est premièrement le
plus qui était à proximité de la plage
ça vaut plus cher mais les maisons astor
c'est comme ça suis en constante
croissance y est tellement d'achalandage
puis de me demande je vois maintenant
sur la bnb check-in ma maison c'est
minimum des mails par mois
j'en ai touché des maisons parce que on
pensait peut-être justement ce site va
râler comme ce qu'ils louaient une
maison tanguay avec une gang d'amis qui
restait le seul mettons trois semaines
petit le par curiosité j'allais voir
comme l'i les plus belles les pêcheurs
liliane haïti c'est incroyable des
maisons d'architectes gagner des prix
sur bonne place dans le milieu de la
flotte et dernier de la jungle avec un
bout de plage privée il ya personne
d'autres autos c'est comme ça le
regrette c'est combien ça coûte
construit pas puisque 500 millions us et
un
creux de la main d'oeuvre la main
d'oeuvre coûte en fait c'est moins parce
le terrain le montage audio ça me
coûtait 150 milles au pij et un 8000
pieds carrés
qui est la maison tu mets ce que tout ce
que tu peux mettre dessus la maison que
ce pays mettant 450 millions us à bâbord
ici 1.5 million d'accès salaire comme
hoarau mais pour la bosse et c'est comme
ces 450 c'est comme les villes à bali le
désaccord pas possible c'est à 300
pièces max la nuit la ccph au bassin la
menara coûte pas cher là-bas puis un au
costa rica aussi c'est vraiment pas cher
puis encore là ça serait super chère
maman fait que c'est ce jeu peut-être
regarder pour
construire quelque chose là bas j'ai
beaucoup d'amis québec labeouf est que
moi je suis comme quelqu'un quand je
prends ma retraite je voyage depuis je
suis enfin ok c'est comme de propre
parti où est ce que je veux bien boire
mais mes blagues chaque place des
loopings la retraite quelque chose que
tu entrevoit où toi c'est plus
tranquillement délégués des leggings et
puis rester l'homme est comme un peu sur
le side gérer moins en moins ou bien tu
veux vraiment année prendre ta retraite
retraite non je pense que je m'en
voudrais si je prendrai ma retraite mais
ça se répète comme des délégués des
ligues et puis juste avec le petit matin
comme j'ai jemma gestion immobilière
d'abord plusieurs propriétés en dessous
des pieds j'ai des managers ainsi
d'abord des gestionnaires immobiliers
des qui s'occupe de tout qui mon père
aussi propriétaire de plusieurs
immeubles fait que c'est un truc que tu
en as ensemble tech c'est quelque chose
que je veux vraiment avoir passé pour
moi c'est quelque chose que dans les
guerres mais enfants même si tu es
pouvoir profiter le
plus de
buts
ouais ouais mais a surtout ici le cph
tabourot québec laisse comme giberti un
james comme je vous disais tantôt pis je
voulais acheter une bâtisse mais il va
rien y avait ce que je recherchais
c'était vraiment soit pas possible à
acheter ou comme il y avait juste rien
c'est mon pied mon chum on a acheté
notre maison comme avant la coved en
2019 puis une chance qu'on l'attend le
may 19 parce qu'il est mon dieu ça
aurait été pas possible est-ce que là
est ce que tu encore des contacts avec
la russie où ces
attentats mais jamais eu non j'en ai
jamais eu ma grand mère est partie de là
bas enfin la com mis ses enfants dans un
couvent ici puis à la partie basque est
infirmière fait partie au venezuela qui
est parti travailler là bas est revenu
plein en iran dans un couvent solennel
comme ils étaient tous dans des couvents
puis c'était vraiment comme comme dans
l'ancien temps magique sommes plus
vraiment de contact avec eux c'est pas
quelque chose qui m'intéresse chez
jeannette en russie à moscou est passé
ici si tu rates tu dois faisait quand
même en russie - mais je mettrais pas
râler mais comme c c'est dingue c'est
vraiment dire que c'est très pauvre
dans les extrêmes souhaité été très
riches et les très pauvres sont charles
au québec des nids-de-poule ben là bas
les nids de poule c'est gros comme la
table c'est vraiment pas bien entre nous
ouais ouais les gens boivent le matin
s'ils passent par tous comme une
bouteille de votre que c'est comme saint
piat ce qu'ils valent à ios c'est
vraiment pas cher les illicites c'est
quand même assez triste c'est c'est
vraiment très très très pauvre
fille tu t'es tu dis mais totalement
comme le manque est élevée c'est comme
dans l'ancien temps ce qui était déplacé
dans un couvent habitudes est ce que il
ya eu un clash avec tout un mode de vie
pis le sien ou a tout le temps été folle
open dif obama s'était complètement le
contraire parce que vu qu'elle a été sûr
protégé puis a été comme dans un couvent
mais moi m'a laissé toutefois que moi à
16 ans j'habitais plus chez nous j'ai
peut-être mon chat mais je travaillais
j'allais à l'école comme à moi toujours
laissé faire ce que j'avais à faire
parce que l a jamais eu cette
opportunité l'atacama comme toujours des
collègues dans ses locaux ouais c'est ça
c'est parce
que j'avais à faire piqueur ça fait en
sorte que le
super 14 qui chute à cause de qui je
pense qu'on est destiné pour passer à
travers un certain chemin c'est
seulement mon destin ça c'est ton chemin
tous les gens qui nous écoutent qui
veulent
plus sans savoir sur toi qu'est ce qui
s'en vient et où s conduit c'est quoi
les
blogs
que je viens de sortir ma piaule et on
fait un peu de casse les codes sont à
bout elles m'ont parle de que ce soit
l'industrie 3x de sexe des deux conflits
coptes et de vie de famille on parle de
tout vraiment un peu comme vous sans fed
mais vraiment sans tabou le temps on dit
beaucoup de même on
suit plus
est ce que vous êtes constant sur son
ventre en parle un peu avant d'entrer
sur
les failles puis les gens je voulais
filmer c'était plus compliqué avec nos
deux oreilles parce que moi j'ai tout à
partie puis monde cham et janry studio
fait quand même un peu plus d'ici là
qu'on faisait une fois aux deux semaines
c'est que l'on est en retard d'une
semaine faut que je leur passe mais moi
je pense que c'est une habitude que je
dois apprendre que je me dis mon métier
d'athlète et pieds nus rien là qui va
venir dans mon horaire si ce test est
beau king là bas sinon jamais faire par
la part le broker sur un bon moyen
d'avoir un sentiment de proximité fans
puissent vraiment l'impression que
ça crée vraiment notez déjà sommées de
se renforcer moi je fais beaucoup de
stars il a peut-être le monde qui me
connaît mal comme christian gosses parce
que je pense comme 150 story mais les
gens écoutent 950 story.com sont ils me
répondent tout le temps affecté si
j'arrive quand même à voir cette
proximité avec leur travail les stories
kesha beaucoup beaucoup d'adjectifs
tiges à poster comme les 90 la business
je finis les s'il ya des vidéos à ce que
moi qui m'en tiens aux chicanes la gorge
était comme moi je monte t comme je veux
montrer que c'est pas tout du bon pied
des jioi genk des maisons et cissé c'est
de la merde des fois c'est vraiment de
la merde pisse à la fec autant mon
couple que mes enfants pis
s'il faut savoir comment bien équilibré
ce qui je veux montrer la vraie vie
témoigne aussi y ait pas de ya pas de
france le sur les réseaux le ch
quelqu'un what you see is what you get
mais je vais pas montrée juste du beau
j'en suis à cancun c'est comme ça c'est
simplement une blonde ça c'est zéro mois
fait tout ce chemin je vais montrer la
vraie vie puis les gens ils sont proches
de moi justement parce que c'est pas
juste tu es à l'eau je m'entraîne james
chez les pros restait grave encore c'est
la vraie vie ouais ouais
youtube pas de casse les gens qui
écoutent le chantier de la 12e l'époque
ya
vraiment tout ce qu'on pense vraiment en
parler politique si pour les gens qui
sont les plus pressés au camac il est ce
qu'on va mettre de l'huile sur le feu
on bat vraiment tout et j'ai mon lit
king sorti way disponible en ligne je
rends lingway hôpital et même place que
parce que tout le monde achète et les
noës abbé jean coutu et
ge bah oui parce que tout est avec
pratico-pratique moi ils m'ont signé
l'année passée au kanak mais la cagnotte
et aucun accès comme livre de recettes
vegan 1 2 2 par 4 puis 1 mark twain tous
cas pour l'épauler tout le monde sait
que les gueules la construction célébrer
mama équilibré mais clame olivier
sarraméa m'en contenterai coucou way
très très cool merci infiniment
merci
du contenu excellent tu as tout un
podcast combien
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur une pétillante répétions vous
abonner pour trop de leur part mais
aussi trop de longs mois et trois pièces
par morlaàs par mois et vous avez les
pas de carte en avance acquise avec les
premiers de votre groupe d'amis avoir
quitté les podcasts qu'ils allaient
avoir pouvoir avoir une avance quand
vous allez tuer la dynamique entre les
amys tout le temps avons une avance sur
les jobs en avance les entre deux toits
mais avec pétillante une avance sur
l'humanité complète en plus en plus
parce que le chèque le podcast unis
voulaient nous entendu davantage on fait
des encore moins de filtres à préchac
podcast avec là on vient de finir de
tourner le podcast on vend josé on va
chill et nicole non nicole il est
maintenant évident comme un fils
travaille à plat ce détail est là mais
on jase on parle de conversion qu'on
m'aide à voir mais ce si vous voulez
avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous c'est exclusif
sur pékin il faut s'abonner abonnez vous
nos tombes de france
google go
team gunnar
[Rires]
gren qui
paraît
bien venu sans filtre présenté par
caisson